ولا مسؤول في البانتكون للجزيره انها
حادثه تصادم وقعت بين مقاتله روسيه ومسيره
امريكيه من طراز ام كيو 9 فوق البحر
الاسود واضاف المسؤول ان الحادثه ادت الى
فقدان المسيره الامريكيه التي كانت تنفذ
عمليه استطلاع في الاجواء الدوليه فوق
البحر الاسود واوضح ان التصادم وقع بعد
قيام مقاتلتين روسيتين من طراز خوي 27
بتعقب المسيره بطريقه غير مهنيه وغير امنه
حسب تعبيره
هذا وقال منسق للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكي جون كاربي ان
حادثه اصطدام المسيره الامريكيه بطائره
روسيه كانت النتيجه تصرف متهور وغير امن
وغير احترافي من الجانب الروسي حسب وصفه
واضاف ان اعتراض الطائرات الروسيه
للطائرات الاجنبيه فوق البحر الاسود ليس
امرا غير مالوف واوضح ان المسيره
الامريكيه كانت في المجال الدولي فوق
المياه الدوليه ولم تكن تشكل اي تهديدا
على اي جهه واكد ان الولايات المتحده
ستواصل العمل في البحر الاسود وفقا لما
تنص عليه القوانين الدوليه وانه اذا كانت
روسيا تريد بعث رساله لواشنطن بعدم طيران
فوق البحر الاسود فان هذه الرساله قد فشلت
حسب تعبيره
تمتلك مسيره ام كيو 9 الامريكيه مواصفات
تكنولوجيه عاليه ويمكنها القيام باكثر من
مهمه يبلغ طول الطائره احدى عشر مترا لعرض
عشرين مترا مع الاجنحه ويبلغ وزنها فارغه
اكثر من طنين وتتميز بقدرتها على حمله
صواريخ مثل هل فاير ويمكنها الطيران
لمسافه
1850 كيلومترا دون تزود بالوقود كما تمتلك
المسيره نظام رادار ينقل البيانات لعدد من
الطائرات او المواقع على الارض ويشار الى
ان التقارير افادت باستخدامها في اغتيال
قائد فيلق القدس الايراني قاسم سليماني في
بغداد ولاحقا زعيم تنظيم القاعده ايمن
الظواهر في العاصمه الافغانيه